Police and law enforcement officers are aware that our memories are malleable.
And they've developed techniques when investigating crimes or accidents to help
diminish the possibility of false memories. One thing they do is to separate
witnesses immediately so they cannot talk to each other. This way, what one
person remembers from an accident is not contaminated by what another person
remembers from an accident. Another thing they can do is to be careful with the
types of words they use to ask questions. For example, Elizabeth Loftus
examined how the types of words that people use to ask questions can influence
our memory of an event. For example, in one study participants were assigned to
different groups. Participants saw slides of pictures of cars that collided and
they were asked to estimate how fast the vehicles were going, but they were
asked in different ways. There were five conditions. The participants were
asked to describe the car accident as if they were an eye witness. Participants
were asked how fast a car was going when they hit each other, smashed each
other, bumped each other, collided with each other, or contacted each other.
Depending on which group they were in, they heard a different ending of the
sentence. A week after this, participants were asked if they saw any broken
glass in the pictures on the slides. Participants in the smashed condition
reported the highest speeds. After that came collided, then bumped, then hit,
then contacted. And when they were asked about the glass, participants in the
smashed condition were more likely to say yes they saw glass in the pictures.
So, here we see the type of question or type of word that is used to describe
the accident. Influences the persons memory of the event and may actually
modify the persons memory. Again, this experiment demonstrates how easily our
memories can be changed. Our memories can be easily distorted by the type of
question, and information that comes after an event. This can cause inaccurate
recall or reconstructive memory.